je vous remercie madame la ministre mais
je ne pense pas que vous ayez répondu à
la préoccupation que j'essayais de vous
faire partager la ruralité n'est pas un
sous territoire ni pour les immigrés ni
pour ceux qui vivent d'ailleurs le
problème de l'immigration n'est pas
celui d'une répartition territoriale
mais d'un contrôle d'une maîtrise et de
l'application des textes notre ruralité
pardon accueille déjà de nombreux
étrangers et en particulier les réfugiés
ou les exilés d'y craignent mais c'est
pas du tout le sujet que que sur lequel
je vous interroge et ceci de manière
choisie et humaine la ruralité n'a pas
effectivement aujourd'hui le cœur en
berne mais nous nous refusons à devenir
une réserve où on les parquerait au
moment où nous battons pour la prise en
compte de quelques sujets majeurs pour
notre ruralité service public école
santé aux ânes nous renvoyer cette
vision de leur ruralité et cruelle et
méprisant il semble que pour certains
nous ne soyons destinés qu'à accueillir
les migrants pour soulager les banlieues
vous l'avouer presque et les éoliennes
pour éclairer les urbains la ruralité
sous-thérite sous territoire de la
France c'est non et je pense que c'est
pas le message qui a été envoyé par les
Français au moment de l'élection
présidentielle je vous remercie